en primer lugar bueno pedirle si podría
resumir no para nuestra audiencia
internacional lo que son los principales
lineamientos del estatuto
claro pues el objetivo principal es
salvar guardavidas no y haciendo esto
específicamente para personas que huyen
de sus países por cuestiones de
conflicto de persecución y la convención
que como bien dices hoy cumple 70 años y
ha ayudado a salvar a millones de vidas
digamos a través de la historia y cuál
es hoy el escenario global para los
refugiados pero untable eso por un lado
y si cree que este estatuto tiene
todavía elementos y vigencia para
encarar la situación de los refugiados
hoy en el año 2021 hoy más que nunca
tiene vigencia y hay más de 82 millones
de desplazados forzosos en el mundo y a
través de la convención el acnur y la
comunidad internacional los apoya los
acoge los
y ayuda a que se integren a sus nuevos
países en alrededor del mundo
entonces la vigencia y la importancia de
la convención sigue muy muy presente